[Music]
all right now it's good afternoon
so if you were coming here expecting to
hear greg wilson who is a well-known
educator talk about the future of data
science education in 2022
you're going to be disappointed because
he wrote the abstract for this talk
and then he talked to me and said you're
going to have to give it
so my name is carl howe i'm the director
of education for our studio and i'm very
honored to be here
to talk to so many wonderful people if
you want to know a little bit more about
me
uh i have actually have a very old and
decrepit website
at karlhow.com but it does have my full
resume one of the things you should know
is this is my third
career i started my life as a software
engineer
i have a degree in computer science then
i became an analyst
i don't know how you feel about analysts
i was an industry analyst
and one of my jobs was to predict the
future
and and i love this quote that came from
a danish parliamentarian
which is that it's difficult to make
predictions
especially about the future
but i actually thrived in that business
for about 20 years before i became
the director of education here i
actually did also travel around
the world teaching big data before i
came here but the thing that drew me
here was our studio's mission
and you heard it from jj this morning
but i think it's worth repeating
we want to equip everyone regardless of
means
to participate in a global economy that
rewards data literacy
and one of the ways we're doing that is
we have become a public benefit
corporation we think this is incredibly
important
we want this these tools to be around
for hundreds of years
and we're willing to play the long game
to work hard to do this
now when i joined i i decided we needed
to have a mission in our education group
as well
and by the way when i say our education
group there's a variety of people greg
is on the education group allison hill
garrett groliman who's not able to be
here because he's on family leave
but we also include people like hadley
wickham jenny bryan
all the folks in the tidyverse team so
it's a great group
but we established a mission which is we
want to train the next million r
users actually we did a hashtag and i
talked last year
about this and you can actually use that
hashtag to tweet about it
so let me talk a little bit about some
of the things we've done to get there
greg has actually had headed up a group
that is also
our certified our studio instructor team
we have nearly 100 certified instructors
already
i'm just showing you some of the
pictures i don't expect you'll be
actually able to recognize anyone
but here at our studio conf i think this
has been incredibly exciting for me
that we have held 19 workshops here
led by a teaching staff of over a
hundred
and teaching 1300 students on monday and
tuesday this week
i believe and i'm happy to take contrary
views
that this is the largest art education
event in the world
in addition to this we also have other
contributions many of you have seen our
free online books
our packages for education open source
materials on github
free academic licenses for rstudio pro
products
if you're an academic using our products
for teaching you get free licenses
and and our annual survey of how people
actually learn are
so we're doing a lot but i'm sad to say
it's not nearly enough we need to do
more
and the reasons is that when we survey
our users
we discover something important which is
that most our users are self-taught
48 percent almost half are self-taught
which means no matter how wonderful an
instructor i am
i'm not reaching most of the world
and one of the challenges i see is that
data science
faces serious challenges in the next two
years
you know you would think two years from
now it's it's within our
within our vision it's right on the
horizon
but i think there are some big changes
coming
and in the immortal words of yoda if
you're not
afraid you will be so i'm going to go
through three challenges
to guide you through this the first
is the data explosion frankly we're
drowning
in data nowadays i'm going to use just a
really simple
metric from ibm that said
90 of the data in the world
was created in the last two years
ninety percent so if you think of data
science as looking for a needle in a
haystack
we have a problem because if our
look if we're looking for a needle in a
haystack today
we're going to be looking at 10
haystacks by 2022
and by the way by the time we get to
2024 we'll have 100 haystacks
now i know most of you say oh but
computers get faster
it's no big deal moore's law isn't going
to break it isn't going to bail us out
this is moore's law factor of two
increasing computing power every 18
months
actually originally a marketing campaign
done by intel but it's worked out pretty
well
this is the data explosion if we look
out five years
moore's law gives us a factor of about
four and a half
in terms of computing power the
data explosion we're going to have 46
times as much data
in five years so we're drowning in data
and we're not really prepared to process
it
secondly i want to talk about something
that i really don't have to explain to
you
but it's such a great topic and it's
something we really have to pay
attention to
it's irreproducibility results
sorry i can't even say the word
unreproducible results
we no longer trust science this is a
real issue
and and it's not because science is
inherently
untrustworthy it's that we're kind of
screwing up how we do it
um there's a great article in physics
today i'm by the way i'm borrowing from
goloman's slides here because they're
just so compelling
uh he heard about this uh this study
that was being done about supercooled
water
published in physics today and they
published the paper
they basically just cooling down water
past the had to be very clean water
and past the point of freezing down to
very very low temperatures
and two labs ran the same experiment
and they got different results and after
seven years of
suing companies like nature
i think it was published no it's in
physics today of course they after suing
the publisher
they finally got access to the other
team's data and what they discovered was
there was a bug in the code that caused
their
studies to diverge now you can blame
this as just
one isolated institute but as a famous
amgen study was done in 2012
that discovered that when they looked at
landmark results
the foundations of their very science
they could reproduce only six
out of fifty three six
out of fifty three and let's not just
blame the farm industry
this is everywhere if you look in the
field of psychology for example
they're only able to reproduce 36
out of 100 important psychology studies
and if we look at economics it's the
same story
29 out of 59. look at nature and science
the two premier publications
in the scientific world 13 of 21.
and by the way if you want the
references they're right here
so i did some very serious research on
this
i worked very hard on it i did 21 coin
tosses
and ended up with 12 heads
and if you look at the ratios there you
know economics is doing
less well than the coin tosses
and nature and science are only just
barely doing better
needless to say this caused a few
headlines
and it ranges from the new york times to
the atlantic
and to the wall street journal
now i just want to try to put this in
perspective
in the united states so not the world in
the united states
the cost to the biomedical industry in
the united states
for irreproducible research is estimated
to be about 28 billion dollars
now just to put 28 billion dollars in
perspective that's enough money to buy a
latte
for everyone on earth from starbucks
or if you like might be a little bit
more fun
if we just simply say you know i can buy
everyone in this room with this money
your own island in the bahamas while
supplies last
this is a serious issue and that's just
in the united states and that's just in
the biomedical industry
it's trillions of dollars worldwide so
this is a real thing unreproducible
results
is something we're going to have to
address in data science education
all right the third one is i think i'm
not sure how many people are going to
see this one coming
it's fake data data has just become
another way to lie if you look at
the headlines you see this every day
we had the brexit issue where they were
promised there was going to be 350
million pounds for the nhs that's not
happening
hundreds of climate skeptics have
convinced
an international campaign to get rid of
the net zero targets
and there are people donating millions
to anti-vaxxers
now i blame this really on media
explosion we're get overwhelmed with
media everywhere we go
it didn't used to be the case that you
would get the latest headlines
on your person within seconds of them
being published
so the world is sped up we're
overwhelmed with media
so what do we do when people are
overwhelmed with media
they turn to their trusted sources the
most trusted people
in the united states or in the world
even they are people like
facebook google and twitter
they're relying on their friends for
their facts
the royal society of open science has
actually published a paper on this
called fake science and the knowledge
crisis ignorance can be fatal
and the real danger was actually
illustrated very well by the television
series chernobyl
the real danger is if we hear enough
lies
we no longer recognize the truth when we
see it
now i'm going to illustrate this with a
true life example
and some of you probably know this it's
a very famous study it's called the
rogoff reinhardt model
anybody heard of this before yeah a
bunch of you
um this was published in 2010 i believe
and
the conclusion is very simple two
harvard professors
published a report that said when a
country owes more than 90 percent of its
gdp
it slides into recession and they had
done studies and models and they were
very proud of this
and this was the foundation for
austerity
in europe for the next 10 years well it
turns out that
uh some folks at university of amherst
uh
said well this is a great study it's the
sort of thing i can give to a graduate
student to reproduce
so a fellow of thomas herndon took this
data and discovered a small problem
he actually talked to the harvard
professors they gave him their very
detailed excel spreadsheet
and when he looked at it he saw this
over on the right hand of that table
there's a little selection there if you
notice it doesn't cover all the
countries
in the list they missed five countries
at the bottom
and so they've just been dragging this
column across the spreadsheet
and they missed these five countries if
you include the five countries
their conclusion is completely different
there is no
implied descent into recession
rogoff and reinhardt's results weren't
reproducible
yet they led to this
they led to the the cut off of a lot of
medical care
provisions for the poor because the
claim was
that greece couldn't afford it and
britain for that matter
all right so let me finish up here we do
see some hope
um and i just want to say one of the
things about analysts is they tend
they're just somebody who reports the
obvious
preferably before someone else does so
i'm just going to finish up with
here's what we need to be doing we need
to focus on teaching
data science not coding science
so we've got some challenges over the
left-hand side let's talk about the
changes we need
and this one's going to be real obvious
we're going to embrace statistics
data science embraces statistics on real
data
why because when the data gets really
big you can no longer process all of it
which means you're going to have to do
sampling that requires statistics
why real data because real world stuff
is just
messy and if you don't know how to deal
with it you're not going to be able to
do data science well
there's a wonderful book coming out from
janine harris at washington university
in st
louis called statistics with r i've only
gotten a preview of it but
this is a wonderful narration
a wrongful story of dealing with real
world data sets
using r my second point is we're going
to have to use public processes
and here you know good data science
relies on our markdown computational
documents and open processes
all of you are probably pretty familiar
with our markdown we love it
but i don't think people have really
understood the huge impact
of being able to take our process for
doing science
documenting it and creating papers that
we don't read
their papers that we run but we're going
to need a few other things
we're going to need curated data so that
we can trust the data we work with
we're going to need computational
documents those are pretty easy
but we also need open source publishing
of sources to allow others to run our
work
i'm just going to wind up here with the
fourth point
which is fake data how do we combat fake
data
well we need authoritative storytellers
we have to democratize data science and
here i'm going to just do a shout out to
a few
organizations and people i'm going to
start with
our ladies
probably the most amazing organization
for democratizing data science in the
world
they got together and they said let's
take the data science to the experts
the women who are working in these
industries and by the way it's not just
women it's everyone
but they found a way to really engage a
new audience
but our democratized experts must be
viral storytellers
and here i'm going to ask you a question
who would you trust more to diagnose
your illness
a data scientist who learns in medicine
or a doctor who learns some data science
anybody going for number one okay
well here i want to give a shout out to
stephen kaduke he's a md and phd
at the children's hospital of
philadelphia and he
has created a program for doctors to
teach doctors
they don't want to hear from nurses or
other folks they want to learn from
doctors
and he's promoting r to do that
another person i'm going to give a shout
out to is desiree de leon and you're
going to hear from her later
hey she's a fabulous person
and i'm not going to say anything about
that because she's talking
and the final person i want to talk to
is a farmer
a farmer who was sitting in my r
markdown an interactive dashboards
course
on monday and tuesday he's from brazil
he came here to learn how to create
interactive dashboards
so he could help other brazilian farmers
do farming better so those are our
challenges
we need to focus on teaching data
science and not coding
science and it's really too soon to tell
whether this is going to be successful
but with your help
each of you can help us overcome the new
challenges in data science education
and help everyone regardless of means
participate in a global economy
that rewards data literacy thank you so
much
okay carl we we've got time for a couple
of questions
and the first one is um how do you see
traditional schools and traditional
curriculum fitting into all of this
yeah um well there's a lot of
ways we could we could work that but one
thing i see is the data science is going
to go
uh more broadly um
the tier one colleges don't need our
help community colleges
heck yeah um we need a lot of a lot more
democratization to the community
colleges
is one thing i'm working with a bunch of
groups including the concur consortium
on pushing down statistics and
specifically
learning statistics with r into high
schools
big problem with high schools by the way
is their curriculum is already full
so a lot of this is extracurricular but
a lot of new curricular
coming out of these organizations to
address high schools
and the other one is you gave a good
shout out to our ladies are there any
other organizations that you think
people ought to be putting their
attention to that may not be as famous
yet
um our open side i think is a great one
um
[Music]
any others uh actually you're probably
better better at that than i am i
haven't met everyone yet
i'm working on it though it's a big
planet that's true
kenny
awesome
yep
okay there's an organization called stat
prep
stat prep.org okay thank you very much
another round please for carl and we'll
get our next speaker up
you